[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
he's smarter than you why who thinks
he's smarter than you why who thinks
he's smarter than you
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shot
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers jones has
fake callers
this is
[Music]
corporate tank over censorship debanking
arrest
at that tyranny at that look at that
corporate tankover censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that corporate
takeover censorship d-banking arrest
tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser he's a disgrace
and he's a disgrace
and he's a disgrace and he's a
look at disgrace
trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
toilets
and showers elements of bathrooms
times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
my bags are mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
bring my mango
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy don't want me to be healthy and
highway robbery is what you're doing
[Music]
welcome everybody we've got a packed
stream today all leading up to today's
town hall which is going to be at the
top of the next hour 6 p.m eastern
that will be only on the other youtube
channel on the pacman live youtube
channel but that's an hour from now and
we'll have time
to get to that but that is today
do not adjust your television mobile
phone or
computer i guess or toaster maybe people
are watching us on a toaster
but that will be later so we are going
to
get to that for sure
the big news the mask mandate on
airplanes is no longer in effect at
least for now although it might go back
on we're going to see
uh also the big news of course alex
jones infowars filing for
bankruptcy
chakuseki
weighing in via super chat saying david
i'm deeply worried if infowars is
bankrupt who will continue their
groundbreaking coverage on the forced
gender reassignment surgery of frogs yes
also transgender salamanders are now
teaching kindergarten and that's
absolutely
groundbreaking for a lot of parents in
florida
let's see what else we've got another
name says they made white house
bathrooms gender neutral
and look what happened you had elected
officials flushing documents down the
toilet coincidence
i don't think so oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad hayley says david sir did you tan
your apple bags today exactly yes tucker
carlson
when i say this i'm not exaggerating
tucker is very strongly looking into
tanning testicles for
testosterone increase as we know tucker
carlson is the picture of masculinity
to the nth degree the epic alpha male
and along with his tasseled loafers and
bow tie
he is looking at adding to his
testosterone with testicle tanning
that's on yesterday's show haley clearly
gets the reference from yesterday's show
uh okay
big thank you to the old tired road
porsche polly my bag of mangoes twist of
the day
rachel link beef stews and john the
elder dragon and cosmos kicking us off
with eight
twitch prime subscribers today thank you
thank you very very much also uh adam
gingrich says
bless
the united sheish this is just a
stush what's that what's this word
supposed to be
stutter stick touch stutter stick i
don't know what that is
and god bless
the united states
exactly
a statistic oh i see
yeah
hold on do i have my alex jones
impression globalished internationalist
trotskyite socialist shun like obama
trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
right that making sense to everybody i
hope that it is okay let's just get
right into it mask mandate no longer in
effect
the following airlines have gone
mask off or i guess we would say mask
optional delta
american
united
south west
alaska jet blue
spirit and amtrak amtrak not an airline
but still going mask optional so here's
my thought on this okay
um
a trump appointed judge said
the cdc is exceeding its power
by requiring masks on planes what's the
baseline what's the basis rather
well the judge said the cdc
can put in place guidelines for
sanitation
the judge says that's the sanitation of
the airplane not the people on it and
thus
since the masks don't sanitize the
airplane
it exceeds the cdc's um power
and therefore masks are off
now we talked about this on the bonus
show the funny thing to me about that is
that applied six months ago that applied
12 months ago like if that's your it's
not like the explanation is
it's no longer necessary based on this
data or that data or whatever
it's just oh no the cdc can't do this
and the judge makes the ruling two weeks
before the masked mandate expires anyway
so to me it reeks of an opportunist an
opportunist judge who wanted to make
headlines which she did
which she did
now as far as they're no longer being
masks on planes
i don't know how much longer masks on
plane was going to last anyway
so
they've they're gone fine and now people
can decide i will no longer travel on a
plane if people won't be masked or i
will everybody can decide for themselves
the one thing i think is not fair was
the fact that pilots came out of the
cockpit
during flights yesterday to say they've
just announced no more masks and
everybody starts taking them off
because there were people on those
flights who were there
because of the
added level of safety that they
perceived or had
as a result of the masks being required
so to me
it would seem logical
to say it's effective at midnight don't
literally have people ripping masks off
on the plane that's my critique of it
you know i understand the masks were
gonna go in terms of me flying
um
yeah i don't know i mean i
obviously like okay
i'm not gonna be dissuaded from flying
the question is will i continue to wear
masks on airplanes i just don't know i
have no flights planned right now
um
so i'm not sure
i'm not sure but this this was
essentially inevitable i even have some
videos here
of uh
here's one pilot coming out and
announcing the removal of masks and
everybody starts remember when trump had
covid and he went to the white house and
he took the mask off and he was
breathing super hard
it's sort of like a similar thing april
18th the divine administration announced
that the transportation security
administration will no longer enforce
the federal mandate
requiring mass in all u.s airports
non-foreign aircraft
[Applause]
like this is very cringy to me
it's like you know
it's like the equivalent of what burning
a bra i mean i i find this very dumb
um here's another one
whoops hold on a second let me go back
up
current weather over in fresno it's
mostly cloudy tonight good visibility on
the ground a little breezy later in the
evening and a current temperature of 26
degrees celsius that's about 79 degrees
fahrenheit
as of 5 pm uh today masks are no longer
required on u.s domestic flights
please feel free to keep wearing them if
you would like to but this goes for both
employees and passengers it is now an
option
we'll be on our way as soon as we get a
final head count and all the bags are
stowed in the house apartment so please
sit back relax and enjoy the two-hour
flight to fresno all right
uh here's another one i already know and
i can tell by your behavior already now
this is all my official company ipad
does it get any more official
now
and right down there there's some like
blue blue red white blue red yellow and
white southwest logo stuff i shall quote
effective immediately employees and
customers may choose whether they would
like to wear a mask
[Music]
all right you guys get the picture and
alaska airlines pilot congratulated
people
it's over
immediately
congratulations
[Music]
all right uh let's do one more
um i've been going up and down this goes
to south florida and new york for about
35 years
worked through the blackout 911
the masks were worse than working
through 911 guys it was crazy stuff and
it's kind of a crazy world
we just got an announcement a few months
ago some of you may have seen the press
release today that a judge overturned
the mass mandate
my company
[Music]
it's almost like a phoenix rising over
the horizon
you remain rebirth if you're compromised
you certainly can keep your mask on
everybody be well sort of
anyway so that's the deal with the masks
the masks are coming off and uh i i
think you know it was if it wasn't
yesterday or today it was probably may
3rd and everybody needs to do what they
want i just think dropping them
mid-flight
probably not logical given that
everybody booked the flights on the
basis that people would be would be
wearing masks all right so that's my hot
take on that i don't have too much else
to say about it i do have two other i
want to give away two memberships okay
this is a really special moment for me
by popular demand
we set up a system now on our website we
added a box we're very box oriented here
like a cat cats love boxes and we do too
we added a box on our website that lets
you select this is a gift
and when you do that
i get a notification that we've received
a gift of a membership
and just now adam gingrich
as well as danny thompson just sent two
gifts and these are beautiful gifts
these are high-priced gifts
we have a list of 662 people waiting for
memberships and i'm gonna give away two
right now james jackson you get a
membership and eric frederick you get a
membership you'll get an email in the
next day or two
telling you click this button and then
you can claim your membership all right
so
i encourage you if you are an individual
of means
and you have a membership you can give
memberships away by checking the box is
this a gift coupon codes apply to
memberships that are gifted like for
example
if i type in the code obama
six dollars becomes a dollar ninety two
and you can still give that as a gift
if you gift a month the person only gets
a month if you gift a year the person
gets a year okay so be be make your
judgments but we will keep giving these
out if you i don't even know if this is
legal a judge has overturned gift
subscriptions
and it's a trump appointed 22 year old
judge if you can believe it if you want
to request a free membership it's very
easy go to davidpakman.com
free membership
very very easy to do we will give and
receive
give and receive throughout the stream
also quick thank you to pink and blonde
and tempst
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 11 and 12 and yes the town hall
is today the town hall is today at the
top of the hour but we've got other
stuff to do first let's continue a trump
rally at disney world
apparently caused total chaos for people
going to disney
i hate disney as it is this just
encourages me to stay away take a look
what a trashy situation huh
a trump standout outside of mickey mouse
oh i
i didn't even realize they're protesting
disney i completely forgot about this
whole thing it's not just math now
that's bad it's also disney what do you
guys even remember what did disney do
why they're mad i i covered it but i
don't even remember is it because did
disney featured
gay people in a commercial or something
what what does anybody remember what it
was
the don't say they're they're against
the don't say gay bill okay
disney didn't like the don't say gay
bill so trumpists are now protesting
you know i hated disney before this and
i still have no interest in going to
disney but whatever people can do
whatever they want uh but
very very strange stuff okay um this was
an interesting moment michael knowles
who i was recently on a show with
appeared
somewhere with appeared at yale
with ted cruz
and a student in the audience asked if
it would end world hunger
would ted cruz perform oral sex on
another man interesting question
interesting question let's see
my name is evan um
assuming that would end global hunger
would you fellate another man
i ask him to repeat
well actually so i i do have an answer
to this all right i i actually think it
is better that the haley answer this
you know there was a line and there's a
line in america now that's weird is did
is ted cruz was that sexual harassment
what
that was pretty cringy did ted cruz say
that the woman should be the one to
answer it is that what he said
psycho about that yale thing i think
that's what our questioner is alluding
to
uh like uh like a typical left-wing
undergraduate you are engaging in
consequentialist ethics okay so
consequentialist ethics means you
evaluate the ethics of something by its
outcome so like if instead of saying how
we would get it i were to say to you
okay
um is ending is ending uh
i mean sending world hunger is a good
example is ending world hunger and
saving ten thousand people a day
something we should try to do and i go
absolutely then you go okay would you
murder two babies in order to achieve it
and the idea if you're a
consequentialist would be well if you're
saving ten thousand people a day then
the murdering of the two babies would by
definition be okay
and consequentialist ethics can be
valuable and or not depending on the
situation you are attempting to justify
flagrantly
immoral behavior to achieve a good end
and i tell you my friend the ends do not
justify the means absolutely
absolutely
i mean it is kind of crazy in the sense
because when it's like
hey would you eat only avocado and
walnuts for the rest of your life but
like then everybody gets to live to 150.
i mean i don't know why why do i why am
i the one who has to eat the avocado why
why is ted cruz the one who has to
perform oral sex on a man but but it's
like that's a pretty big deal ending
world hunger you know
i i am curious with that young fellow if
it would solve world hunger
would you vote for donald trump
anyway so a little tour of
consequentialist ethics
in uh i guess at yale
um
pretty pretty wild pretty wild stuff for
sure
uh let's give away a for you a few more
memberships adolfo oh wait a second
that's that's not that's someone getting
their free membership
um amber fritz
and christine hall have just gifted two
memberships on our website those
memberships go
to alan wall
and alex gilman congratulations al
congratulations alex and alan you have
just been uh gifted two subscriptions
also thanks to x broken and twist of the
day for the twitch prime subs very much
appreciate that guys if you're just
joining us we have a david pakman show
viewer town hall at the top of the hour
40 minutes from now it will be streaming
live
only on the pacman live youtube channel
not on this channel
not on twitch not on facebook at the top
of the hour we're going to pinch off all
of these streams we'll go live on pacman
live and we will take calls remember
website members get priority we
calculated you're about nine times more
likely to get on the air
with proper base rate calculations
please we're doing it statistically
correctly if you are a website member so
a little extra incentive to sign up
today you will get uh priority access uh
tonight bay photo says it's odd how
something as simple as a mask can become
the hallmark example of political
polarization you'd think something
monumental happened yesterday judging by
people's reactions i know
it's uh
it is weird but let's continue with the
content
um blaze tv host mocks the idea of
transgenocide
by joking about killing trans kids this
is elijah
schaefer let's listen okay so what are
you talking about to go well he goes
well the problem is is that there is
this mass genocide happening of trans
kids from fascists and i just said where
yeah where listen to this they go well
in texas which i'm like i'm well aware i
live here yeah so do you i'm assuming
yeah we all have to put a trans kid and
dragon behind a truck
yeah
how many trans kids did you kill this
week uh six uh they come with a toll tag
josiah remind me you told me you did
three i did four i was trying to beat
you this week oh not bad is this is this
comedy or is this political analysis do
you guys know what's going on i don't
even understand this what show is this
wow good this is why they say crowders
team's better at everything whether it's
views it's you know oh you got bits and
writers and then it's like oh can i not
at least get the trans genocide on my
side the blaze ships us the better trans
kids i feel really really cheated it's a
murder you should talk to them um i feel
really cheated because i oh i get my
patriot supply ads and stuff meanwhile
you get trans kids to genocide trans
good supply yeah it's a pretty good
company is this
i know it's not funny but is it supposed
to be funny
nobody knows yeah it's hard to tell okay
my chance
they come in a tackle box it's like a
half dozen my trans cat
and you kill him any way you want it's
pretty good it's only in texas though
apparently yeah apparently i didn't know
that because i've been killing them
everywhere so is this what they they
think
is this what the right thinks counts as
satire maybe that's what like who
exactly who is this aimed at that's a
good question
steven crowder fans yeah i don't know
ted cruz uh
fans it's very weird
i started in california talk about the
trail of tears i did version two it's a
new movie yeah
12 years of slave i've been doing it for
28. yeah wow what a great show guys very
very strange stuff joe asks what are you
doing about the massive dumps from the
standpoint of cats in your garden yeah
so okay here's the situation people know
you know about my infamous backyard
gardens there's a cat that
has moved in
and is now using one of my raised beds
where i very strongly planted some stuff
as a litter box and one of the things
about you know densely densely populated
new york is there's no way in hell i'm
gonna figure out where this cat lives or
who it belongs to so i could go and by
the way i think if you have an outdoor
cat you don't do i don't know anything
about cats but if you have an outdoor
cat and someone said can you keep it
inside the whole premise is you want it
outside right like i'm guessing
cat owners don't make an outdoor cat
indoor cat because they're using
a raised bed
as a litter box am i right about that
would that be offensive to the cat owner
if i was even able to find the cat owner
right
so anyway so here's what i'm going to do
i am going to go and get a chicken wire
i'm going to wrap
everything in chicken wire it's not a
stray it has a collar i'm going to put
chicken wire walls around my raised beds
i got an ultrasonic animal
element i don't even know what it's
supposed to do but apparently when it
senses motion it's solar powered you
just stick it in
the raised bed
and when it senses movement from animals
it like releases some noise that cats
don't like so that then they run away
um
and i might even someone said that you
could do cayenne and black pepper all
over the place that it won't hurt your
plants but that the cats really don't
like it
so i know there's people who are going
to suggest significantly more aggressive
means of dealing with the cat trust me
i'm aware that there are more aggressive
ways of dealing with the cat
but um i you know i'm not i'm not
looking to kill animals
um
humans also don't like the noise of
those well we'll have to i'll i'll have
to figure that out then
some people might have to be annoyed by
the noise but it's a pretty nightmarish
situation i'm not gonna lie
it's not as bad as having to wear a mask
on a plane but it's it's pretty bad
i wanna say thank you to monster adam
david lee as well for the twitch prime
subscriptions number 17 and 18 17 and
18.
uh very very exciting
um
couple other super chat sir have you
seen jesse waters dating tips discussed
on the five i have not
if someone sends it to me i'll look at
it on the next stream i just have way
too much stuff going on today let's
continue in fact here is um geraldo
rivera
makes the accurate point that immigrants
commit crimes at a very low rate
undocumented immigrants which is true
and janine pirro just says no it's not
true when was the last time you heard of
an undocumented immigrant committing a
horrible crime
they are
disproportionately law abiding other
than the offense of coming across one of
the truths
yeah there's one that one of them and
then
you know one of them
what about the per capita what about the
fact that so you want to admit 20 30
million are here no i don't want to but
i want you to know that these people
yeah geraldo's completely right you know
i know geraldo was like a big trump guy
for a while i don't know if he is now i
don't even care geraldo's completely
right and it just makes perfect sense
why does it make perfect sense
it's sort of like uh i recently read
this book about
the serial killer richard kuklinski
and one of the things kuklinski would
say
is when he had a body in the back of the
car
he took extra care
to drive the speed limit and he checked
his brake lights and all of these
different things
and in the same way
not that being here illegally is like
murder but the point is if you know that
you're in a situation that is
problematic legally like being in the
country undocumented it make makes
perfect sense that you would be extra
careful to avoid attracting the
attention of police
it's just it's obvious intuitively
and it's also backed by the data both
documented and undocumented immigrants
commit crimes in the united states at a
lower rate
than natural-born citizens yes richard
kuklinski also known as the iceman
as many people are pointing out
very much uh
interesting book by philip carlow i
recently read oh by the way people have
been asking for this and i have finally
done it people have been saying david
sir please tell us what finance books we
should read sir sure exactly i have now
put together the list at davidpakman.com
finance these are
these are books i would recommend on
personal finance okay
davidpakman.comfinance one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten if
you read these ten books you will not
only be ahead of 99 of the population in
terms of knowledge of personal finance
you'll probably be ahead of at least a
third of financial advisors quite
frankly that's not a joke
it's also not an attack on financial
advisors there's just a lot
most people are not good at their jobs
it's not anything special about
financial advisors okay if you read
these 10 books you will be ahead of 99
of the population
and at least 30 percent of financial
advisors
okay financial advisors hate me because
of this one simple trick
davidpakman.com finance and yes if you
use the links here to get these books we
do get a small very small commission
smaller than trump's
hands even okay
so
that's that uh let me give away a few
more memberships laurie parkinson has
just gifted a membership
oh just laurie laurie your new member
number 19 and that membership goes to
susan malfeld susan you get a membership
thanks to laurie i also want to welcome
marco janet
as well as oh and lori parkinson signing
up for herself as well putting us at 21.
thank you very much guys you can gift a
membership at joinpakman.com
you can get a free membership by
requesting it at davidpakman.com
free membership i do want to be clear we
have 662 people waiting right now and i
would love to clear those
as quickly as we possibly can
let's continue
uh this video has been floating around
this is of
christian uh songs being sung on a plane
it is vomitous
let's look
[Music]
now here's the question i have not
gotten a straight answer to
this is not a commercial flight right
i'm guessing this is like a missionary
charter or something like that i can't i
i have a hard time imagining delta would
allow this and also there's a couple
people not wearing masks and this is
from days ago can somebody confirm this
this was a this was like a charter for a
missionary group or something right this
is not just a commercial freight flight
also the outside of the plane here i'm
not familiar with this livery for any
mainstream airline
it was okay
it was a chartered flight yeah it's
vomitous anyway
but
the fact that it's a christian flight
makes it more logical it makes it more
logical
there's someone staring at the emergency
door longingly
yeah i know i know uh anyway so
i've i've never been on a flight like
that
um this is really weird this is a guy
named uh this is max blumenthal
he was on the jimmy dore show
and he said that when he had the virus
that
it felt digital
now i don't know what the hell that
means donate plasma today please
convalescent plasma supply
light and heat supposing we hit the body
with a tremendous uh very powerful light
maybe you can maybe you can't i'm not a
doctor right
this is really weird guys i've met max a
couple times perfectly nice guy
uh but i don't even understand what this
means when you got covet
did it didn't it feel digital
oh god
you know
when when uh when a friend of mine had
covid he felt it was like 192
k bit rate like the audio was just
better it wasn't like 128 or 64.
it was just like high fidelity
when you got covet
did it didn't it feel digital
i don't know what you mean but it feels
digital it just doesn't feel like it was
it was too wacky even for dore like
anything else
when you have to me it felt like well i
got omicron and it felt like i didn't
get delta or the first one so i got the
most mild version so far i think i even
have the last version of omicron and it
was like it was like i had the sniffles
it was like nothing i wouldn't even
mention it to people if we weren't in
the middle of a pandemic and i know i
had covid because i got tested so
so yeah i wouldn't even have mentioned
it so to me it didn't feel anything
except like the mildest flu i ever had i
once had a stomach bug in 4k can you
guys believe that
it was crazy
i mean when i when i had it it wasn't
bad or threatening in any way
but
it felt unlike any other
virus i'd ever contracted so my
understanding of this
is saying that the virus felt digital
it must mean that it's sort of cow
towing to the idea that it's like a
man-made bio weapon right like i don't
even know what that would mean
it's got to be the it was created in a
lab thing
is that probably what it means i don't
even know digital it was completely
unusual and there was a sort of digital
feeling okay i once had a hang nail in
surround sound i couldn't even tell what
direction it was coming from whether it
was my hand or foot i thought it was my
right thumb it was actually my pinky toe
because it was just coming it was like
dolby 5.1 it was crazy okay a few super
chats david do you believe tucker's end
of masculinity is a result of trump's
ban on men
and we will ban men i do
uh and thanks to rayleen for the super
chat as well yeah i don't know what what
max is talking about it felt digital
very strange
very very strange
thanks to skittle stew susanna floor
holly gorak and bobby for the twitch
prime subscriptions putting us at 25. i
really uh appreciate that
um once i had bronchitis
in binary it was coming out of me and
only zeros and ones my doctor didn't
know what the hell was going on
uh he suggested a reboot and i was like
i don't even what
what buttons do you press to reboot it
was very strange
really really strange
um
yeah i once sneezed an extremely high
frame rate that did happen too okay um i
haven't watched this yet my colleague
john sent this to me apparently
bill maher was on some show with bella
thorne
and
uh i guess he kind of like mocked
anxiety
let's see what this is about
i fell into weed because of like serious
oh this is beautiful stomach issues and
anxiety and like crippling anxiety um
and weed has really changed my life and
what is what is it with your kids and
anxiety what is causing all the anxiety
ah i think everything the world the way
that the world is now it's you know
constant
just mad
everywhere you look it's so bad you know
what
i find this to be
on your natural day i find this to be a
disingenuous argument because
your generation doesn't know what's
going on in the world so how can you be
that [ __ ] concerned about what's
going on in the world i know what's
going on in the world i should have the
anxiety and then i guess in another clip
he clippy mocked trans people and i
guess bella thorne
didn't didn't like it boy it doesn't
even it doesn't even matter because
everybody's switching their sexes
constantly they're switching sexes
no i'm not kidding about i mean i'm
kidding about that but people do switch
sexes a lot more than they used to you
know there's a lot of trans you know i
always
see that in the paper about somebody who
has switched their sex which i'm all
that's what makes you that's not what
blows your dress [ __ ] all the way yes
bad [ __ ] fat [ __ ] bad [ __ ] oh
bad [ __ ] bad [ __ ] be who you are
yes clubs right perhaps makes me happy i
mean i think there's some uh money to be
made in some sort of exchange with
everyone switching where like you know
if you need a penis take a penis if you
have a penis give a penis you know like
if there was some
exchange uh maybe bitcoin could be
involved and you could
you know wow bella thorne finding this
absolutely hilarious as you guys can see
uh
what a weird show
what a very very strange uh strange show
i want to say thank you to cooper munger
cooper just gave a gift of a membership
at joinpackman.com the lucky recipient
of that gift is evan spry evan you get a
membership we'll be emailing you in the
next couple of days and uh you will be
able to collect on that really very much
appreciate that let me uh continue
this is um cultural critic and arbiter
of ideas dave rubin um
was brought on fox
to react to people who protested ted
cruz and i guess he said they should be
punished
hold on a second but that's isn't that
their speech though the silence
conservatives at their school and
campuses all across america
and i gotta tell you when you come out
of school
most places you work are not safe spaces
most bosses are not going to be overly
worried
about injuring your fragile feelings
and so
i think the point of education is to
prepare you for life and that means
encountering things that make you
uncomfortable that make you doubt that
make you question
that's really what education is all
about
senator cruz along with many others also
signing an open letter demanding that
yale punish the disrupters or the
protesters at last month's free speech
event author and reuben report now i'm
sure dave rubin as a conservative
anti-regulation libertarian would say no
people shouldn't be punished for legal
speech dave rubin joins us how to react
dave what about the the senator going
back to the eye of the storm with that
school of thought which was remarkably
unpopular with the student body
well good for ted cruz and of course ted
cruz is completely right here look you
have a right to protest it's the most
american right there is you can voice
your opinion and you can do it
peacefully okay and properly and that's
what the free exchange of ideas is all
about what you can't do is use your free
speech to shout down somebody else you
can't lock doors you can't pull fire
alarms the litany of other things that
we've seen
hold on a second
pulling a fire alarm
that's not speech what
isn't it shouting fire in a crowded
theater that people say what is it you
can't pull a fire alarm what the hell is
he talking about i mean i don't think
you're allowed if you pull a fire alarm
for no reason i'm pretty sure that
that's against the law but
is that considered speech
is it just the wrong euphemism i don't i
don't even know what he's talking about
you're not allowed you you can have
speech but you can't pull a fire alarm
i don't even know what he's talking
about
okay every college in america and until
the administrators the professors the
donors until they all decide uh this
can't happen anymore it's going to
continue to happen i suspect at this
point the institutions are probably too
infected and we just so is
so how how are people supposed to
protest ultimately is it there's a
speaker you don't like and you can
protest outside
but if you're inside you have to be
quiet when it's their turn i mean i'm
not saying i'm big on shouting down
speakers either but i'm not i'm not
saying that i think
there's a kind of complicated area where
it's like okay well the speaker is here
i'm not going to shout the entire time
at a certain point shouting the entire
time is disturbing the peace i think
or disorderly so you could be removed
for that maybe
but
where is the line exactly just need to
build new things because it doesn't seem
no matter how many times you guys talk
about it that's right about it or ben
shapiro talks about it they just keep
marching so maybe we just actually need
new things well
that's a great point but the irony of
that event we were looking at where the
the speakers were shouted down is it was
a free speech event right and didn't
everybody speak i mean shouting is speak
speech right i don't know
again i'm not saying it's my thing like
listen
i've done a bunch you know dozens of
speaking events
if someone was committed to just
screaming the entire event
i would expect at a certain point
they're escorted out and if they refuse
to leave nicely at a certain point you
call the police and you say these people
aren't even welcome here this is not a
public venue we're trespassing them you
know we are indicating please leave like
i would expect that that would happen
eventually
but i don't i just don't even really get
what their argument is and they didn't
want to hear one side of it and i think
it was about a week after that then a
federal judge
suggested an appeals court suggested he
sent an email out to other judges and he
said i don't think we should hire clerks
from yale law school because i don't
know that they can be fair given the
fact that they won't even listen to both
sides of a story
but wait a second so it's okay to punish
the protesters because of their speech
for employment purposes i mean
but that's okay
these people are bonkers huh
well brian first off it's 2022 irony is
long since dead so there's nothing we
can do on the irony factor uh but yes i
mean this is the problem because it's
not just that we're allowing these kids
to shout down speakers who are invited
by the school i mean we're in ted cruz's
case we're talking about a sitting
senator right
it's not just that it's that then the
education
that these kids get the very things they
learn the things that law students
should learn related to the exchange of
free speech and protests oh dave rubin
knows what they should be doing in law
school give me a break okay all right so
another hot another impeccable hot take
from uh from dave rubin let me say thank
you to terry schwerin terry just gifted
a membership at joinedpakman.com the
lucky recipient of that membership is
going to be emery bigger emery bigger
congratulations you have just been given
a membership i would love for you guys
to gift a membership we have at this
point
663 people
waiting desperately all these people
they're up all night waiting for a
membership okay we have a new box on our
website when you go through the sign up
process check the box that says this is
a gift
that will then pop up a membership we
can give away we have 663 people waiting
if you want a membership for yourself in
all seriousness it is our primary
funding source so i would love for you
to get a membership at joinedpakman.com
and of course we always love people
supporting via twitch as well in about
15 minutes we are going to be going into
our david pakman show
viewer town hall the viewer town hall
will be streaming on pacman live
and uh everybody will be welcome to call
in there will be an express lane for our
website members but that's going to be a
really great thing
um
udef
heck you says why is a private charter
plane singing their religious songs
vomitous would you say the same thing if
they were jewish or muslim
absolutely okay
uh let's see what else we've got
jermaine pickett david sir your show is
winning bigly thanks for the streams and
coverage thank you
i appreciate that very much
um do we want it's been so long do we
want to squeeze in one whitney voicemail
let's just see what she's up to we
hadn't haven't heard from her for weeks
also um
i noticed that walsh was like
uh saying like what is flaky materials
or whatever
and i looked up his
and it's like super duper close to
uh
a urinal
what the hell is whitney talking about
i don't know what on earth she's saying
what the hell
that was bizarre
um let me see if i've got
anything else here as far as voicemails
go
the eggman called in about testosterone
hey dave i think testosterone is going
down in men right now in our society
because of tall buildings skyscrapers
shalom
and we will ban men okay
so there's that tomorrow i'm going to be
covering this arrest from syracuse new
york where a 10 year old boy who stole
allegedly a bag of potato chips
unclear if they even had saffron
safflower oil or what kind of oil they
had
um he was pretty aggressively arrested
it's a horrible horrible thing to see
what are you doing
like a baby to me
that's what i'm doing i don't know what
you're doing i just see you snatching my
partner
so what's the what's going on there he's
stealing stuff if he breaks into your
house to steal something nah man what
are you saying a bag of chips so y'all
treat me like an old cold blooded
[ __ ] killer whoa
all right so 10 year old arrested you
know what's crazy i i vividly remember
when i was probably 12 and my little
brother was 10.
i remember
being at a grocery store
and going through the checkout
and then we get home
and all of a sudden my brother takes out
a king-sized snickers not even regular
size this was like the big boy you guys
know the king size right
and
my parents say to my my brother sir
where did you get that
and he says at the grocery store what do
you mean
and he had stolen it he had stolen it
and um
you know my parents said well we're
gonna go and we're gonna give it back
because that's wrong you can't do that
we didn't pay for it
and so they went back and
to the grocery store and they gave it
back and of course the grocery store
said thank you for being honest
and it was like a big you know lesson
imagine if the police were called
because my brother had stolen his
snickers you know it like it was wrong
um
but
it's like lesson learned you know you
had to go back and apologize and give it
back what what what are we doing here
my brother was not black that is true
that's absolutely accurate you've
correctly assessed
the race of my brother he was not black
um
how mad were my parents i don't know i
mean they said it's wrong said it's
wrong you can't do that they said sir
you can't do that
and he he gave it back so we'll talk
about we'll talk about that more
um tomorrow here's a florida woman
harassing i guess i guess
i i don't actually see the kid in the
video but i guess they're harassing a
trans kid
and now here's the thing
oh man
whenever you say
in this setting when we're looking at
someone on
video this person's mentally ill are on
drugs
there's blowback where it's like you
know you're not supposed to say that
you're stigmatizing mental illness or
you're stigmatizing drug addiction
i'm not doing any of those things but
this person does not seem to be
of their right mind
i don't know if it's mental illness or
drug abuse i don't know what it is
but a lot of this stuff
is
people who are not they they they don't
have their wits about them
i think is what i'm trying to say you
know i'm not a mental health
professional etc exactly green man
exactly just take a look at this okay
or you have a agina
i mean guys like what the what the hell
is going on here
you're a woman you're a girl
what'd she say there's no such thing as
what
what was that there's no did anybody
catch that
let me just go back a second there's no
such thing as what
there's no such thing as data
did she say data
oh they them they them oh my god
there's no such thing as they them okay
all right all right there's no such
thing as a datum
that's stupid
you're one person
why not what's wrong with females
is this the mom right here
i like that that's a great line it's
wonderful for you to have an opinion on
that
that's really kind of like saying fu man
that is great
i should use that with guests i love
that you have an opinion on this i
really do now unfortunately in fact
do you understand that
oh my goodness
wow that went over her head
the mom says you could be yelling the
sky is blue
but you don't yell it in a child's face
and the woman goes the sky is blue
there's no way around it the sky just is
blue she's completely going on well
gender you want to get it just don't
yell it in the face of a child
i'll smell it in your face that's my
favorite i'm using those
yellow in my face that's why i was
completely probably yelling at me i
think it's silly but if that's what you
guys just don't do it to the kids
well yeah so anyway i don't know whether
that's drugs or what that is
but um or or some kind of you know
mental illness i'm just not sure but
pretty pretty wacky stuff going on there
for sure thank you to braided dragon i
really appreciate your twitch prime
subscription your number 28 today also
want to say thank you to christina
hillard christina just did an incredibly
great humanitarian act christina just
gifted a membership and now thanks to
christina
nick white
gets a membership nick congratulations
you're next up whoever next gifts a
subscription it will go to ryan del
percio ryan is next up for website gifts
if you whoever is next would be gifting
one
to him and that's uh that's a really
exciting thing br madding via super chat
says serious question does the david
pakman show filter certain super chats
before putting them on screen no no they
just pop up did youtube eat my five
dollars no biggie just curious so the
ones that are under five dollars don't
pop up at all
so if it wasn't actually five dollars i
i don't know but we don't filter them
derek says i guarantee the lady in the
white shorts behind her brought potato
salad with raisins to the protest
lady with the white shorts
lady with the white shorts hold on i
didn't see a lady with white shorts
oh right there oh okay
oh man
all right okay and then uh here is our
friend walter masterson talking to
someone about
some kind of uh there's something
reptilian going on yeah england with the
queen of england and her family is what
i understand they could be uh
we could even go reptilian type people
maybe and a reptilian for the viewers
that don't know what is a reptilian uh
rip tim is like a ship shift shaper uh
shape [ __ ] it's a shift shaper not a
shape shifter it's a shift shaper
shaper they they they can they can
change their uh uh
well ship to uh reptilian to uh to uh
human
you could see it in their eyes you could
see the evil they changed their ship to
a reptilian well ship shaped or what
what they are is uh it's a ship shaper
they ship
they shape ships they took the queen
mary ii turned it into a tugboat
shift shift
shift shape it's paul schaefer from the
paul shaffer band pops up
yeah ship shapers yeah
they uh they change their shape in their
ship they do that so like a
shape-shifter yeah that's what that
oh that's genius
oh man that is that is crazy
okay
uh any other people out there uh that we
should know that are reptilians yes the
jews i mean guys let's just let's call
it for what it is okay
this entire reptilian shape-shifting
thing
it has some pretty serious anti-semitic
overtones as many of you know i know
many of you you know it's like let's
just cut the crap and get get to what it
is here
um well you just look in their eyes
right you see the darts
dear god
man isn't that wild that is really
something else
tremendous job as always david says
harrison via super chat thank you
brody says early voting starts next week
in the texas democratic primary runoffs
can i get a shout out for progressive
cisneros and tx28 and jan mcdowell and
tx24 don't know who they are couldn't
possibly say one word about them one way
or the other but everybody get involved
in your local
elements of elections very very very
important thanks to very serious man for
the twitch prime subscription on that
note
this stream will end right now we're
going to the town hall okay right now
we're doing the town hall three minutes
from now okay
the town hall will be live on our other
youtube channel it's right now okay
youtube.com pacman live i'm gonna go
offline here
everybody go to live it's only gonna be
on live we're opening the phone lines
wide open
members get priority it's today in three
minutes people asking where is it it's
on pacman live when is it
it's in three minutes how do you call in
davidpakman.com discord okay i'll see
everybody then we're gonna get set up on
the other channel standby